the cookies in Manipur state are taking
up arms improvised weapons manufactured
for a makeshift militia
members of this mostly Christian
minority group are standing guard
they fear more attacks from the mete the
predominantly Hindu group that has them
greatly outnumbered when they attack us
we fire
not far away Mayte are also taking up
weapons their Villages have also been
attacked they blame the cookies
women are among those keeping watch at
this roadblock
they say their Community is showing
restraint
if we start thinking that the government
is not looking after us then our men
will take up arms this will definitely
lead to war with guns so that is why we
want peace we all want peace
both sides of a long history of violent
clashes and deep-running ethnic tensions
that erupted in May when a Court ruling
threatened the Cookie's long-standing
protections including land rights troops
were deployed with a shoot on site
policy and a curfew imposed to keep the
peace but the cookie don't trust the
mete dominated State Police and resist
the Army's campaign to disperse their
militias
our enemies may say okay but while we
are in our position to defend ourselves
sometimes we are deserved by the armies
they sometimes they wanted to deploy our
bunker this time we really want to drive
out the armies from our bankers
as the coffins pile up bitterness is
growing where mixed communities once
existed many have left to live with
their own as the cycle of violence goes
on
Vinton Monahan Al Jazeera